[موسيقى]
يكمن جمال الموضة الرقمية في أنه
يمكنك ارتداء أي شيء من النار إلى الماء
فهو بلا حدود تمامًا ويعود إلى خيالك
[موسيقى]
نصف أنفسنا بكوننا دار أزياء علمية وتقنية.
في الأفلام
، والآن نشاهدها تنتقل
إلى تجربة المستخدم
بالنسبة لنا شخصيًا ، يتعلق الأمر
بالحرفية والجمال
وتعقيد هذه الأصول الرقمية التي تمنحنا
قيمة تتراوح قطعنا من 1.5 إلى
1e من العملات المشفرة التي
تساوي حوالي 1  000 دولار أمريكي في الوقت الحالي
أعلم بشكل صحيح ،
نبدأ من خلال رسم أه حقًا نستخلص
كل الإلهام على
غرار الطريقة التي
ترسم بها دار الأزياء الفاخرة التقليدية
مجموعاتها ، فهناك مواد رقمية مختلفة
نوعًا ما خططنا لها
مسبقًا  المظهر ، إنها تقريبًا
عملية خلط ومطابقة جميع
المراجع الخاصة بك وتجميعها
معًا مثل اللغز ، وهي عملية
سهلة للغاية في Digi  tal world ،
هذه إحدى الطرق التي
نلبس بها الأشخاص رقميًا حتى تتمكن من
رؤية الصورة تحتها ثم يتم تراكب ثلاثي الأبعاد
في الأعلى ،
لدينا مجموعتنا القادمة باسم
Mesmer حيث
نضع أزياءنا الرقمية وأيضًا الصور الرمزية التي صممناها
الصورة الرمزية أولاً ثم يتم
التلاعب بالملابس مع إضافة تفاصيل مثل
المواد التي تعمل بها الفرشاة أي نوع من
الزخارف ، لذلك هذا من مجموعتنا الجديدة ،
هذا
الفستان جميل للغاية ومنحوت للغاية ويفتح
، وفي النهاية سيتم
تحريكه أيضًا بشكل متحرك للغاية.  طريقة سلسة يمكنك من
خلالها تبادل الملابس بأسرع
ما تضع مرشحًا جديدًا وبالطبع
أنت ترتدي أزياء ليس لها
تأثير مادي.
بدأت في متابعتنا في وقت مبكر جدًا
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ، لذلك
تواصلنا ورأينا فرصة نحن  في الواقع ،
صممنا المساحة بالكامل التي صممناها
لعرض الضوء الذي صممناه بالطبع Grimes his
Avatar جنبًا إلى جنب معها والسلام
الذي كانت ترتديه
الموضة الرقمية في الوقت الحالي هو
لتصبح أكبر ظاهرة في
الثقافة ، يمكنك أن ترى ذلك من
دخول Legacy Brands إلى الفضاء وأيضًا من
الشركات المحلية مثلنا والتي
كانت رائدة في هذا المجال في السنوات
القليلة الماضية ، نحن متحمسون جدًا لمعرفة كيف
يمكن للعلامات التجارية أن تتحد معًا  في مساحة
تدور حول الإبداع المشترك
والمجتمع والعمل معًا فعليًا
ومن الجيد أن نرى مزيجًا من كلا
العالمين لأنه بالتأكيد طريقة
جديدة لا نستهلك فيها الموضة
فحسب ، بل نختبرها
والأمر متروك لنا حقًا  كمصممين
للمساعدة في قيادة الناس إلى الموضة
الرقمية وإظهار أن هناك الكثير من
الفرح والجمال في هذا الشكل الجديد من الموضة
، لا شيء يدعو للخوف من التكنولوجيا
هي أداة ، كيف نستخدمها يمكن أن يمكّننا
[الموسيقى]